the other way just real quick I just
want to give a big shout out to the to
the Z bar the cliff kids Z bar this is
not an ad I just want to thank thank you
guys for making diarrhea in a bar mmm
you don't like them well good but the
amount of fiber I'm gonna need my my
patented dump hole to fly open why am I
talking about this it cleans you out
yeah it says Lars yeah I mean it's just
like a bolo meal with a you know a
vanilla drizzle uh-huh in a bar you say
this rizal what's wrong with the drizzle
man fills you up and cleans you out
speaking of getting cleaned out guys we
have some sad news to report and that is
the drip crib I wanted to start with
that actually damn dude it's just seen
it just seems like just yesterday that
the trip crib you know got together and
we thought we'd see you know plethora of
great tik toks great videos and these
guys were you know in my eyes destined
to pump out content yeah but usually
we're here to report that the drip crib
has broken up met what an unfortunate
name dude the dread drew yeah these all
these [ __ ] got gonorrhea bro
who's in the drip crib man let me see
this are they talking uh the thing is is
that they're not even like popular no oh
they're really not like that's why it
was funny when I read that article
whoever the first time we read that
article or whatever about all the tick
tock houses and they listed this one and
I was like the [ __ ] is this I clicked on
it and I had like eight thousand
followers on tik-tok why are they even
in this article and they're living in a
mansion - it's not some modest house
it's like there was a [ __ ] waterfall
and [ __ ] in their house dude
and it's like who how can you who's
paying for this it's a management
company taking a risk on these guys and
investing in them because they're they
think they're they're gonna become like
the next big tick tock house or whatever
yeah it's such a weird concept to just
be investing in houses pumping out tic
TOCs dude look at this one with their
[ __ ] obvious manager this blockheaded
[ __ ] can't even this is content
man right here this is good good content
dude this looks like a team-building
exercise they do not look excited about
this [ __ ] dude it's so forced yeah they
don't look happy at all
what hole oh that's a shame that they
it's honestly a shame they broke up I
would say so
well who is oh no this is Edison Ray's
dad oh so he started that house or was
that just a little collab I have no idea
[ __ ] hate this [ __ ] hmm you know I'd
rather a family get on only fans
together than a family making tic TOCs
while we're on the subject of that
uh-huh
there was a couple posts on my for you
page of girls during the green screen
[ __ ] with their only fans earnings
behind them nice
wild yeah things girls that 8,000
followers are making 50k a month like it
it will probably blow even the most
bullish people whose minds on how much
they're making there's a there is like
there are at least nine women right now
working as like junior accountants that
just heard that [ __ ] and they're like
why do i crunch
numbers why do I say here in Excel
burning my [ __ ] brains out I mean
yeah I like that so I feel like that's
why so got me such a big trend right now
it's because of that you're telling me
that I'm sitting on 50k a month right
now literally I'm sitting on it that's
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] up man but okay what
do you think that's everyone on only
fans it can't be everyone on only fans
right I mean I'm saying like they don't
have that big of a following
you can't generate you can't generate
like organic follower base on only fans
it has to come from somewhere else
that's true yeah yeah that's true yeah
um like it's like patreon weird we're
not like yeah we're not like cool on
patreon or whatever it's just people
come there to support us from other
areas they definitely come there I'm
stupid
no yes no I feel like you could get on
only fans and crews it looking for new
content yeah but imagine your feed your
ping for everyone on your feet oh yeah
you know expensive ass feed yeah flexing
rowhouses $1 they're all private all
locked all these pictures unlock fur for
me of course
oh dude oh my god you man I feel like
only fans turns you into an absolute
sicko like pound yeah you're a you're a
horndog to a high degree you know you
start like having particular you know
about certain types of labia and just
extremely granular and as to what you're
into here's the thing
now I'm gonna I'm gonna just throw it a
wild statistic I've no idea if this is
even close to accurate I bet you like
15% of only fans is nudity oh you think
the rest is exactly the same as what you
get on Instagram okay all right um would
you say that's would you say that's
accurate again I have no idea I'm what
it sounds like it'd be right I think
it's inverted I think it's 15% of it is
like you know you know the
soft softcore I think the rest of it is
just like damn like she sat on that damn
like I feel like a half of it looks like
like science experiments row like it's
like hey you could do that with a
baseball bat
you know that lava lamp has settings
what that is insane
that was Oh Lord she's not putting
flowers in that yeah I feel like it's
our one percenter only fans is either
like extreme attractiveness or like
shooting eggs out of your your hoo-ha
yeah you know I mean like they're like
wing yeah oh that was a whole garden
hose in there oh yeah it just keeps
going and and it's you know I feel like
it's more akin to browsing like he
[ __ ] or liveleak like it's just like
you know it maybe it becomes a thing
where it's not even about the porn
anymore you're like I just got to see
what she's gonna do next because this is
you know what I mean yeah so you think
it's more of like a depraved it's a
depraved Ripley's Believe It or Not it's
just a weird magic show where this is
hiding [ __ ] in their body their point
out and then eat it not putting them in
a giant circle it's just like dude
there's like meter boards and it's like
you know how far can she squirt today
we'll find all these guys tune into her
life she's gonna hit the hundred today
man I have a feeling she's gonna hit the
hundred oh no only fans live streams can
you do though oh my god
I guess like ChatterBait has existed
forever that's that was like the start
of live streaming the porn yeah yeah um
chatter betas did you see a clip of that
dude who put the fake I don't know what
he used but he basically was on like
omegle or ChatterBait whatever with fake
Rach oh these old guys like as soon as
he would get on screen they would say
something super foul like I want to [ __ ]
all over your big tits and then he'd pan
his laptop camera if you'd be like yeah
do you and he's like yeah I saw that
yeah I think it was he's on omegle well
is it I mean I think though I just
wanted to bring up the part where the
guy is still naked looking at him and
goes no like I don't know what witty
thing he said to him he doesn't know he
said he was like do you want to come on
my face too or something he's like no
he's like come on let me see your dick
he's like no it's not hard and he just
starts having like though we heard
argument with I love how all the old
dudes were pretending like like they
were the victim that had situation yeah
yeah like oh you [ __ ] you sick
[ __ ] it's like dude you're the one
sitting on omegle naked and you're 70
years old
waiting for what jerking off in your
shed while your wife does her dialysis
treatment and you're like I want to get
one in right come on today forgive me
[Laughter]
you